i'm giving diana flowers but the second
that she went to take them i then tried
to pull them back
nice so as you can imagine all the air
was sucked out of the room
lily collins spills details on her early
interactions with royalty guys i
formally apologize but i had to keep it
a secret while appearing on cbs's the
late late show with james gordon the
actress opens up about a moment she
shared with princess diana as a young
girl that's james corden showing lily an
old photo of her with her parents phil
collins and jill tableman meeting the
late royal and let's just say the emily
and paris star had some explaining to do
that's my mom and my dad and i and it's
at a princess trust event and i'm giving
diana flowers but the second that she
went to take them i then tried to pull
them back
nice so as you can imagine all the air
was sucked out of the room
i mean but then again i was wearing a
cute dress so who's gonna really punish
me there that memory with princess die
is something lily talked to et about in
2017. i feel very honored to have gotten
to meet her and
you know i'm british so that was a very
special moment for me but yeah i wish i
wish i remembered more of it but that's
not the only royal the blindside star
had a mishap with i was playing um with
some toys with prince charles
and i proceeded to kind of like throw
something at him like throw a toy
telephone at his head
which again all the air was sucked out
of the room so i you know
you threw a toy at prince charles's head
how old were you i was around that age
but about
two ish she's just hanging out with the
royal family now you might be wondering
why lily casually hung out with
england's elite
my dad did a lot of stuff for the
prince's trust so um and i grew up in
england you know i'm british i just went
along for the ride and and i guess i had
a tendency to um to do
naughty things it's a two-year-old i
don't know from england to paris lily
has definitely been making her mark on
europe especially with the release of
season two of her hit netflix series
emily in paris
it used to be so decisive and ever since
i moved to paris my life has just been
chaotic and dramatic and complicated
oh emily you're getting more french by
the day the leading lady opened up to
e.t last month about how they upped the
ante in season two and infused more
french culture i think all of us you
know creatives a part of the show knew
that if we were given the opportunity
for a second season we wanted to have
emily immerse herself more in the french
culture the more of the french language
embracing more of the fabric that makes
up the city of paris which is the people
she meets the food she eats the language
she speaks all of the above and we
always knew that if we got to go to a
second season that's where it would go
and we were just hoping that we would
get to so we were part of all those
conversations and choices and new cast
members which we're so excited about
[Music]